after 10 years i finally figured out how  to put sunscreen on my face every day  without forgetting i looked at all the  activities that i do every day i brush  my teeth i go to the bathroom i shower  it takes 75 seconds for me to put my  sunscreen on my face i was like huh is  there anything else that i do that i  would have time where i can have greasy  stuff on my hands and have time to like  get it off and it won't interrupt my day  i drink coffee every day and so what i  did was i put my sunscreen next to where  i drink coffee so that when i have my  coffee in between i can put the stuff on  in so doing i was able to pair a habit  that i always do no matter what with one  that i wanted to do and it doesn't cost  me more time and so if you can add the  habit without adding the time you make  it convenient to do the thing and that's  why this ends up working